the life that I've built with my husband
the life that we've built with our
children and that's the best stuff
Julia Roberts is revealing what matters
most in her life I'm just super attached
to those four people during an
appearance on CBS Sunday Morning she
opens up about how being an a-lister
doesn't compare to her 20-year marriage
with hubby Danny motor and life with our
teenage kids Hazel Henry and Phineas
it's just never consumed me
being an actor it is my dream come true
but it is not my only dream come true
the life that I've built with my husband
the life that we've built with our
children and that's the best stuff to
come home at the end of the day
triumphantly to them Julia even recalls
a touching moment she experienced with
her daughter Hazel over FaceTime while
she was with her dad at the Cannes Film
Festival oh Dad's you know just putting
his tie on we're getting ready to go and
I said oh
for you are you ready yeah
like she didn't really walk right into
me you know ponytail and I was like a
little eyeliner she was like hey bring
eyeliner Mom what are you talking about
it's like okay yeah I need for eyeliner
who needs eyeliner just can I mean you
know it's just sweet just the Innocence
she's just with her dad it's not about
anything else
he also describes herself as a homemaker
calling it her full-time job when she's
not on a film set it isn't
you know rainbows and kittens every day
but it does bring me a lot of joy and
you do breakfast before school I love
breakfast it's my favorite meal my
younger boy Henry
he's he's my breakfast partner and when
it comes to her life as an actress for
the first time in over 20 years Julia is
starring in a rom-com tickets of
paradise hitting theaters next week
alongside close friend George Clooney I
mean this one came about and with George
as my partner in it it was pretty
delicious Julia sweet bond with George
is something that has spanned over
decades it's just really meaningful I
think we're both really uh devoted
friends and our lives have evolved kind
of in parallel and so now our families
are quite devoted to each other and
that's really nice
[Music]